let's put it this way there are other
species that can recognize things that
are alive and are not alive that doesn't
mean that they have like a deep
conceptual understanding of life but you
know you could argue that we don't
really either you can see different
behaviors that animals have in response
to living and dead things you can see
that uh that some animals are are very
good at recognizing biological motion
that is the movement of living things
and can distinguish that from the
movement of things you know like rocks
or something that are moving but are not
alive and that's really important for a
lot of species
call zimmer welcome to the show
thanks for having me
it's an interesting thing talking about
life and what it constitutes right
because
i think a lot of people have heard about
discussions to do with
euthanasia and assisted suicide and is
this person really alive what does it
mean
philosophical arguments to do with
is somebody in a coma uh discussions
around abortion what constitutes life
during um childbirth and then beforehand
and yeah it's an interesting and
interesting area it seems like it sort
of coalesces a lot of big questions that
people have
uh it really does um
but at the same time uh far as important
as it is um there hasn't been really all
that much
um thinking among scientists about
you know life with a big capital l i
mean when we talk about life what do we
really mean um and so what's really
astonishing is that you know you can
find plenty of definitions of life uh in
the scientific literature um but they're
different definitions and i find if i
if i start talking about life with a
scientist um they might very well have a
definition and it's different from the
one i heard from the last person um so
you have a situation which is really
strange i mean imagine like in chemistry
people didn't agree on what an atom is i
mean
that would be kind of problematic and
yet we're in this situation where
scientists
who study life
life in different forms they just they
really don't agree on what it is they're
talking about why is it so messy
um you know that's a good question i
think uh part of the problem is that uh
is is that
sometimes we're trying to get at
different things when we use the same
word so you know um
there are these uh issues about end of
life you know so um is someone who's on
a ventilator
are are they alive um and so we start to
talk about um
uh you know brain death as being sort of
the definition of the end of life
um but that's really the end of
one person's life um you know their
state of being alive
whereas other people want to say okay
um you know a snake and a tree and me we
we all have something in common that's
different than a rock
what am i going to call that
and
people will say well it's life
and so it's a so it can be a way of
trying to pull things together into
and trying to figure out what they have
in common
um
but you know
but even then you get yourself into
trouble because then you know you think
you kind of have a nice little category
of things that are alive and then
someone comes along with something else
like a virus
and then everyone starts yelling all
over again
so so it's it
it's a it's marvelously prone
to lead to big arguments whose job is it
to work out what life is is it
biologists chemists philosophers
it's funny like i mean if you talk to
a typical biologist you know i talk to
biologists all the time for my work and
um if you uh
kind of stop the conversation and you
say oh by the way i'm kind of curious
like um what's what's your
definition of life i mean what does it
mean to be alive um
a lot of them actually don't want to
really like talk about that at all
um
well because you know you might be a
scientist who
let's say you're a scientist who
uh
studies tigers and you really like
tigers um and you don't know a whole lot
about uh you know uh fungi
they're fine um you know that your tiger
and the fungi have some things in common
but like it's not really your job to to
get too into that like there's enough to
do with the tigers
so um
so for a lot of scientists like life is
so big and so complicated and so
overwhelming that they really just want
to kind of zero in
um you know i mean somebody you know
there's some people who just want to
study you know one protein
so
that's even smaller you know and and you
can get a lot of you can get a lot out
of that as a scientist you can learn a
lot but
it is a little awkward when like this
you know you as a biologist you are
studying life right and yet
um
it can be really hard for to get a
straight answer out of scientists about
that but um
you know so it's so it so then it's fun
to find the the people who really are
thinking about life um and and to get
and who are even trying to do research
on on you know life itself
and to to figure out to learn what
they're trying to do and how they're
grappling with it
but it's definitely a minority would you
say that humans are the only animals
that are aware of life and death
no actually not i mean
let's put it this way um other there are
other species that um can recognize
things that are alive and are not alive
you know um
that doesn't mean that they have like a
deep conceptual understanding of life
but you know you could argue that we
don't really either um so you know for
example like i mean you know a fish
swimming along um
can tell that there's something dead
nearby and will avoid it you know that
you can see different behaviors that
animals have
in response to living and dead things uh
you can uh you can see that uh that some
animals are are very good at um sort of
recognizing
biological motion that is the movement
of living things and
can distinguish that from the movement
of things you know like rocks or
something that are moving but are not
alive
um and that's really important uh for a
lot of species you know um
you
you want to you want to avoid you know
cadavers that could make you sick uh you
want to um
if something's moving
that could be a predator that's going to
kill you or it could be a rock that's
tumbling down and you know that could
kill you too but you need to respond in
different ways you know the rock isn't
going to come after you the predator
might
so um
so there are good evolutionary
benefits
to
being able to recognize life and death
and we can probably
we our own sense of life you know that
we ourselves are alive um that probably
has these deep evolutionary roots too um
just sort of monitoring our own bodies
and that kind of
sense of being alive it's not like a
rational
deduction you know we don't say like ah
from these these certain things i deduce
that i'm alive it's just you feel alive
and what's fascinating is that you know
the flip side is that there is actually
a syndrome a psychological syndrome
where
people
are convinced that they are dead and
they will tell you that they're dead and
they'll explain how they died and how it
is that they're still able to talk to
you after death it's called qatar
syndrome named after a doctor who first
recognized it in a patient in the 1800s
so um so i actually think that like this
sort of deep ability to recognize life
and death
actually kind of gets in the way of our
trying to understand life scientifically
because we sort of we sort of assume
that it's going to be easy you know
because it feels easy
but it's really if you're trying to
understand life uh as as scientists it's
not easy at all what are some of the
stories that the patients that have that
katard syndrome will tell the doctors
um
well they'll say well i you know i
drowned in a lake last year and i've
been a zombie ever since
they're breathing they're talking
they're telling this to them
i
i what can i tell you like uh
the these are the things that you see in
these in these accounts you know and i'm
sure i'm sure that the the psychiatrist
so the doctors were trying to like get
that out of them like really one lady
that was uh worried about being washed
down the drain or something wasn't there
yeah so it's pretty common uh
in these reports of qatar syndrome it's
very rare but there are enough reports
that you can kind of see some patterns
and there is this feeling that people
have that they're just a husk
they're empty inside there's just
nothing there and uh yeah and so one
woman was saying that that's why she
never bathed because she would just wash
away down the drain um and uh
it's
it's it's astonishing um and you know
what there there is just one report that
i've seen where there where some
scientists tried to actually like uh
uh look at the brain of someone with
qatar syndrome and um and what was
interesting was that there there did
seem to be some damage to a part of the
brain that's involved in monitoring the
body sort of taking in information from
different parts of the body and kind of
integrating that into a
feeling
and
so if you're not getting those signals
then you just feel well
there's nothing there i don't feel alive
therefore i must be dead
what are some of the current working
definitions of what constitutes life and
death
uh there are i mean there are literally
hundreds um but you know i think the
perhaps the one that you see most often
uh came about um at a meeting of
scientists the 1990s brought together by
nasa
you know nasa
wanted them to come up with a uh
a plan for
uh looking for life
elsewhere in the universe
and they pretty quickly realize like you
know we need to like agree on what we're
talking about you know what are we
exactly looking for you know
and uh so
you know because like you don't want to
say like we're going to look for
human beings you know like no matter
what you see on star trek where
everybody seems to look just like us on
other planets
um
you you need a broader definition so or
at least a working definition and so
they they settled on something uh was
basically that you know that life is a
is a uh
a chemically self-sustained system
capable of darwinian evolution
so that's what they that's what they
settled on
uh
and so you can find other ones that um
where people emphasize other things uh
you know that they really emphasize
metabolism or you know anything anything
capable of evolving is is alive or what
have you um
uh
but you know i'd say that that the nasa
uh
definition is is perhaps the the most
common one you'll see maybe because it's
one of the shortest all right so that's
life what about death
just that stopping in his system that
used to have it
well you know nasa did not uh ask
scientists to define death
and uh you know really like they were
just more interested in like the
presence of life versus the absence so
like
you know
the moon is not alive the moon is not
life you know because the moon is a rock
um well um
i mean okay
no scientist would like use the language
of death to describe the moon you know
they would might say it's abiotic you
know in other words not having anything
to do with life uh it was never alive um
but yeah defining death becomes a big
challenge um and uh
you know just just in medicine it's been
uh very challenging um
for for centuries really i mean
physicians had this problem where some
of their patients
you know they they didn't seem very
alive but were they dead yet you know
like it was it was a time to you know
dig a grey for them and um you know
there was a great terror actually in the
1700s in the 1800s that people would be
buried prematurely and so you could
actually um request to be buried in a
coffin that would have like a little
hole in it with a with like a wire that
could run out it's a little bell wasn't
it
exactly exactly yeah in germany in the
1800s in the late 1800s actually there
would be these sort of um
uh kind of like funeral parlors but
really what they were they were just
like people would be taken to these very
large buildings
and they'd just be put there
just for a few days just laid out just
and and again they would have a little
bell there just in case
um
they came back um they didn't but but
there was this anxiety because no one
could really say like boom this person
is dead you know the stethoscope
obviously helped things a lot because
you know if you waited for a while and
you know there was no heartbeat then you
know maybe we could agree on that um on
the other hand if someone had been you
know um
uh you know uh suffered from hyper
uh hypothermia you know that might be
kind of ambiguous
the big problem for us came about um
through the invention of ventilators
so you would have these situations in
which
someone
you know had massive brain damage
and uh
would be unable to uh to even breathe on
their own because they lacked the
connections to the brain required for
breathing so
you would uh
you know put these people on ventilators
and you know some of them might be able
to recover somewhat
most of them just you know lived for a
couple days at most and then died
and you know in the 1960s this is
actually at the time when organ
transplantation was becoming a reality
and these transplant surgeons were
saying like
here are all these people who are really
they're they're effectively dead they're
going to be dying very shortly and we
need organs you know and if we wait for
people to die and then
go about
taking organs those organs are degraded
you know so they're worse for the for
the people receiving them
so what if we were to say brain death is
death or what if we just say like
there's no hope that this person is
coming back that's it you know and
so we get you know they want to donate
their organs now is the time we do it
um
this is more you know
this did a lot of this is like a social
agreement you know you can't say it's a
pure science it's us
as people making a decision about these
very difficult situations not just the
difficult situation of the person who's
on the ventilator but the difficult
situation of the person who's gonna die
if they don't get an organ
um and you know there can there have
been you know sometimes there have been
conflicts over that yeah you can see how
perverse incentives could arise here
sure sure and but also you can see how
uh if people don't agree with this
particular definition of life and death
that they might say like no um
we don't want you to declare our
daughter dead and this actually is a
case that happened i write about in the
book where
a girl in california um
you know she
went on a ventilator and suffered
massive brain damage and went on a
ventilator after a surgery that had gone
bad and her family didn't want her
declared dead
and
so she she was actually flown from
california where a death certificate had
been issued to new jersey where there
were these religious exceptions uh made
and
she actually was taken off the
ventilator and um
she was she was able to live for several
years you know in this state um
you know she went through puberty um you
know she was i should say she was still
on the ventilator but you know her body
was continuing to grow
and to mature so uh and then she died of
internal bleeding
and then got a second death certificate
you know it's so it's it's an extreme
exam
demonstration of how hard it can be for
us to agree
on what it means to be alive and then
what it means to be dead what about
cryptobiotic species
yes cryptobiotic species are amazing uh
and uh they are
they are these these uh animals and and
other species that just totally like
make fun of us uh
in terms of our our notion that there's
a clear dividing line between life and
death
um so one example are these little
animals called tardigrades um they're
barely visible to the naked eye they're
in the soil they're uh in the ocean
they're all over the place
and um they're sometimes called water
bears because uh they they have this
cute kind of bear-like appearance um
and
what's amazing is that um
if if they're in a situation where
they're they're in a drought where their
environment is drying out
um this is a situation where we would
just die i mean if you if you lost a
substantial amount of water from your
body your biochemistry falls apart
you're dead
they don't die however they they can
actually survive for decades maybe over
a century completely desiccated
they have been sent out into space and
then brought back and if you just put
them back in water
they're back to the way they were before
and so scientists are trying to
understand well what do the water bears
do what do these tardigrades do and what
they seem to do is they they do these
amazing um chemical tricks to
to uh to go into this
state that sometimes people call it a
third state cryptobiosis
um they uh
and one of the key things that they do
is they start making a special kind of
protein that encases all of their
essential molecules in their cells kind
of like glass
so this you can imagine that these
animals are basically turning themselves
into a kind of a protein glass nothing's
moving
and if nothing's moving on the molecular
level you can't say that you're alive by
most definitions of life i mean there's
no
chemical activity there's no metabolism
that's just not happening but they're
not dead
in other words they're not falling apart
they're not disintegrating um
they're just
on pause and can stay on pause for
decades maybe centuries um and uh it
turns out
there are more and more of these species
uh plants fungi that may be able to do
the same thing yes so that defeats my
previous definition of death being an
absence of a thing that used to be alive
right i mean i i think you know you are
thinking about
you're thinking about
death
you know uh human death you know the
death we know best you know and you know
for the most part um you know if there
is an absence of
certain key things you know if you
if if you can't breathe if your heart
stops if your brain's not working like
boom everything's gonna fall apart um
and you're and you're not coming back um
but that's just
that's not a universal rule it doesn't
have to be that way um that you know uh
life
doesn't really care about our absolutes
that way
what about some other animals some of
the interesting creatures that you found
in your research for the book that have
weird weird ideas about life and death
uh yeah well i you know there are
certainly um
things that uh
features of living things that that
people talk about a lot you know
hallmarks of life sometimes they're
called
and so one of the hallmarks is
metabolism um the ability to to take
stuff in to to to use it to generate
energy and to to produce biomass
and uh you know
metabolism is is chemically speaking
it's really similar in some fundamental
ways from species to species to species
i mean anywhere you look metabolism
uh
involves this one
molecule or our basic fuel atp
so bacteria they they're
making atp we're making atp snakes are
making atp
but there are just some
there are some species that are just
really amazing
metabolically speaking uh
and really stand out they're they're
exemplars and so one example is is
certain kinds of snakes like bow
constrictors or pythons
and so
i i went to to visit a scientist who
studies them and hung out with some of
these massive snakes these amazing
animals
and you know they they can go for weeks
without eating anything
uh and they're fine and then uh then
you know they can suddenly like
leap into action attack something um
whether it's someone feeding them a rat
or if they're you know a python out in
the wild might kill a deer
and then they will suddenly
swallow something that can be their own
weight
and then
break that down so over the next few
days
they completely digested all this after
a little pot of fur coming out the other
end
and so there are some scientists who
have been studying this this amazing
feat of metabolism
it's it's not it's not easy to do this
it actually
you know they're they're eating these
things to get
uh energy out but they have to put a lot
of energy in
you know they have to they have to make
an investment to get all that return
um and so you know part of what is
involved is they have to basically like
retool their whole body like in a matter
of hours so like as soon as they're
starting to swallow something
all sorts of things start to happen in
their bodies their intestinal walls
double in lay in thickness um their
hearts uh increase i think is about 50
percent in size their livers get bigger
i mean we're again we're talking about
this happening
in a matter of hours
and so that way they're they're ready to
handle this incredible challenge of of
breaking down this this whole animal ex
and extracting as many nutrients as
possible moving them around the body as
fast as possible
and then once the uh that prey is
digested
you know the intestine goes back to its
normal thickness the heart shrinks back
down um everything goes back to the way
it was
and so um so
so scientists would love to understand
this better because this could have all
sorts of important implications for
human health you know um
uh
they you know the snakes are are you
know are able to go through these
remarkable changes in organ size or
chemistry in the blood and so on that
might have implications for for diabetes
for maybe even growing organs just all
sorts of uh
potential clues might be there in how
these particular uh
species just you know
use this particular strategy to stay
alive it's like being two animals in one
it really is yeah because yeah you just
you snap into this sort of eating mode
and then you go back to you know not
eating for weeks and then
hopefully a few weeks later you go snap
back into eating mode again and what's
interesting is we think of snakes as
being uh cold-blooded um but the fact is
that um they're they're effectively
warm-blooded when they are digesting
something because they're they're
used they're they're you know using so
much fuel they're burning fuel they're
giving off heat as a byproduct of the
work they're putting into digesting
things so that you know you can
you can serve if you use one of these or
you know heat imaging uh cameras you can
see them glowing uh because of that
they're they're effectively warm blooded
just for that period of time um the ma
their metabolic rate
is um
roughly on par with that of a galloping
horse
um now you know a racehorse might run
for a couple minutes and then we give
them a big prize and say congratulations
but these snakes
they're keeping up that metabolic rate
for several days
when they're just lying there it's it's
astonishing
what about
fungi and mushrooms and stuff they must
be an interesting case study for life
absolutely absolutely you know we
you know animals are
fascinating and bizarre so i just talked
about snakes i talked about tardigrades
but you know they're very close to us on
the tree of life and um you know
if you look further afield you get to
see like weirder things
um things that don't even have bodies as
we think of them
so in the book i write about slime molds
um which are they're not they're not
fungile that they look kind of like
fungi
there are these giant single-celled
blobby
organisms that you can see
in the summer when you're walking around
in the forest
they have very evocative names there's
one species that's called dogs vomit
because that's exactly what it looks
like you're walking along you're like
wow who puked here it's
it's an organism it's alive and
that pool of vomit is actually one giant
cell that is spreading out its tentacles
across the forage floor and feeding on
bacteria that it finds
so scientists love to study slime molds
because you can take a little bit of it
and dry it out take it to your lab and
then splash some water on it and it
starts to grow and those tentacles start
to go grow across a petri dish
um
and scientists have found that um you
just need to give them a little oatmeal
and they're very happy
because oatmeal flakes have uh bacteria
going on them so they'll smell
essentially smell or taste the uh
the oatmeal and they'll just send their
tentacles out across a petri dish until
they find it
now what happens when you've got like
three or four different clumps of
oatmeal on a petri dish
well you know the
the slime all wants it all but you know
it doesn't want to like build like a
whole sheet of tentacles that's a big
waste of effort so what it'll end up
doing is it'll it'll create this
beautiful network of tentacles that's
the shortest distance between those uh
little clumps of oatmeal it's solving a
mathematical problem in order to eat
so scientists have all sorts of fun uh
running experiments with them they put
them in mazes the
slime molds send their tentacles to the
mazes and solve them
they they do all sorts of uh
of these things and
um
and again
this is something fundamental about life
um you know that in other words that a
sly mold
is like us and that it
takes in information about surroundings
and then it does something
it does something to sort of improve its
chances of survival you know it responds
it behaves in a way that's better than
random
um and so you know
the scientists who study slime molds
they like to call this
capacity intelligence so you could say
that that intelligence is one of the
hallmarks of life because
everything from us to a slime mold has
it
um and it's just easier to study in a
slime mold in a petri dish because you
can just run experiment over experiment
or experiment um and they you know
clearly you don't need a brain to be
intelligent it's good because these
slang molds are literally solving math
problems with no need of a brain yeah it
seems like they've got intelligence and
if they do a maze they must have memory
and if they're able to detect things
around them they must have some sort of
senses of some kind
yep they seem to have have all of that
uh
and it's not clear
it's not really clear
how they've got it
i mean so for example um it could be
that that
it's you just need some very simple
strategies to to tap into
these kinds of intelligence
so um for example
um slime molds you know they can detect
where they've been um in other words
like if they've extended out a tentacle
and they retract it back and then
they're extending another tentacle and
that crosses to where they were they can
kind of they can kind of taste
their own trail
and they don't like it
so they'll they'll sort of move away
from that place where they've been
so that is a way for them to not
basically just keep going back to the
same place over and over again you know
if there's like a bad you know if
there's some sort of toxin or
bright sunlight which they hate in a
certain area
and they retract their tentacle they're
not going to make that same mistake
again
because they're like okay that direction
is bad i've been there didn't work out
i'm going to go over here so that helps
them to get around barriers to uh you
know go go through mazes and so on
that's kind of like a rudimentary memory
but it's not sort of
symbolic it's not phenomenological it's
just leaving little trails here and
there and then you detect the trails
again what about yeah you're you're sort
of you're making yeah you're it's like
an external memory yeah so you don't
need a hippocampus tucked away in your
brain you're just like okay i'm going to
like leave a little trail there and i
know that when i
if i reach that again that reminds me oh
i don't want to be here don't come back
here yeah exactly what about thanotology
yeah so thanatology is is this wonderful
name for basically the science of death
um and uh
it's
there there's a small but dedicated
group of scientists who who study uh you
know the science of death particularly
uh there are scientists who are
interested in how
how animals um respond to death
recognize uh that you know other animals
are dead
there's a particular sort of specialty
of thanotology called primate
thanatology which is um
which is particularly important um
for us in terms of understanding where
our own concepts of life and death came
from um so for example you know the
jane goodall
the the famous primatologist you know
she spent years just
sitting with chimpanzees observing them
day in day out and
she would just see things that you
wouldn't see if if you just came to
visit them quickly
in one case there was a female
chimpanzee with with a baby and
um the baby wasn't looking well and then
the next day it was obvious to goodall
that the baby was dead and she could see
that the
the mother was
treating it differently now i was sort
of just carrying it around but sort of
in this sort of strange way just
holding it by a foot and things like
that
and then after a few days eventually let
it go just it
left it behind
and you know there that's just like one
observation but since then in the
decades since the 1960s
there have been more and more
observations of of primates and and how
they respond
to the death of their their
fellow members of their species
and and that you know is is sort of
leading to theories about well um
how
what are our evolutionary roots of our
concept of death um you know we it's
probably you know probably you know a
chimpanzee recognizes
chimpanzee doesn't say to itself oh this
other chimpanzee is dead
but there is a confusion because
you know they're they're looking at
something that that the biological part
of their brain
uh this biological sensing part of the
brain would say well this is something
that's alive it's got a face you know
and so on but um but it's not moving or
it's but arms are at a strange angle
that
living chimpanzees don't have
and it may be that it takes a while to
to overcome that to override that
so we can you know it's not
it takes quite a while in the fossil
record for humans to really show
our you know how sort of modern examples
of recognizing death
you know a a funeral for example and
that's probably just in the past maybe
hundred thousand years that there are
these rituals that humans performed
uh in conjunction with death so in a
million years millions of years before
that they were probably behaving a lot
more like the chimpanzees
have you thought about what other types
of life forms that might be out there in
the universe i watched a series on
netflix not long ago
where they were talking about
silicon-based life
and also of other exotic things do you
look into this
yeah there's actually um
a small but really fascinating little
thread of scientific research that goes
back um 100 years of people trying to
think of alternate life
uh sometimes they like to call it weird
life um
because
they call it weird because you know life
as we know it
on earth is is kind of boring
just in the sense that familiar uh
well
boring in the sense that it's like oh
here's another species like if you find
a specie a new species of bird i can
guarantee
that it uses atp i can guarantee that it
has its genes and code in dna either all
these things i can guarantee it
um i can either i can even get down to
like what is the genetic code that it
uses to
translate its genes into proteins like
just down to that level there's not a
lot of variety
so so all the wonderful variation that
we see and all these weird things i've
been talking about that's in a way kind
of external like
at the core
life on earth is very similar
now that could be because that could be
because there's just one way to do it
there's just one way to do life and and
that's what we see around us and there's
no other way to do it um you know the
rules of matter and energy don't allow
anything else
or
that's just what happened to start here
on earth
or
maybe there were two different kinds of
life on earth
and our form one out and the other one's
extinct
um
we have no idea and and so you know
until we start to go to planets and
moons and and and
see whether they have life at all and if
they do what form it takes will we be
able to say
you know is is silicon life possible you
know chemically speaking
it maybe it could be um you know because
some people have said
well
you know what what is it about dna that
that's so important well it's important
because it's a way to store information
that you can then use to build other
molecules um
well there are there could be ways of
using silicon or some other materials
essentially to work as genes
and
while we wait
to finally get to other planets and
moons to really really look hard for
life
some scientists are saying well
who cares let's start let's get to work
and they're trying to build these
systems in their labs
and so you actually are seeing kind of
alternatives to dna that scientists are
building and trying to figure out if
they can
make them work was there anything else
other than silicon
silicon is is one of the main ones um
there's also an issue about um
the the matter of water
so that's another boring thing about
life is that uh on earth is that it
needs water is that because of the atp
well that's because uh
the chemical reactions that that make
atp possible and uh and lots of other
chemical reactions um they need water to
act as a solvent
um and so you know water interacts with
proteins
in all sorts of important ways
with our dna as well
um and so so we need you know we need
water as a solvent um in our bodies
um
you know there are other solvents you
know um
yeah kerosene you know like
we would not want to drink kerosene um
but maybe kerosene or or or you know
liquid ethane or something like that um
maybe that could be a solvent for some
alternate form of life and
you know this is this actually is not
like a totally um
pure thought experiment because you know
there are some parts of the solar system
some moons where um
there isn't liquid water but there might
be liquid ethane um and so
you know it's it's actually really
interesting to say like well could there
be life there you know
is it impossible for there to be life
there or would might there be some
bizarre super cold
ethane based life
out in our own solar system who knows
one of the coolest things that i looked
at i'll try and
find
i can't remember the name of the
documentary it was something like
different alien worlds a museum it was
just on youtube it was so good and it
sort of moved through all of these
different pretend exhibits within a
museum and it explained how they all
might come about one of the things that
that video said was
the likelihood of finding really really
intelligent advanced civilizations that
are water-based is essentially zero and
the reason is that in order to become
technologically advanced you need
smithing you need to be able to heat
stuff up you need to be able to create
things in ways that allows you to get
outside of your and when you're
underwater that's really really hard
so that was something that i hadn't
considered as well that you kind of have
a a cap on technological development for
a civilization if it's water-based and
um
children of ruined by adrian tchaikovsky
he's got these um
these huge orbs that have got uh super
intelligent octopuses in octopi and um
they're flying these massive orbs of
water around and um it's so it's such a
funny idea well what about given that
we've talked about alien life origins
what about origins of life on earth
so
there again you know the definition of
life is really important because
uh if you want to talk about when life
began on earth you have to say like well
uh
this is the kind of thing that we would
say
was
the original threshold we have crossed
that now is defined as yes
yeah and and so you know clearly like
you know a a pool that's just full of
you know loose
bits of peptides and nucleotides is
an atp that's that's not alive that's
you know that's a primordial soup that
is just a mixture of molecules that
you know
if they were to come together in a
certain way
and
could sustain themselves and reproduce
we might call them alive um so then the
big question is how do you get from one
to the other
and so in the book i talk about
how you know scientists are are
trying to
do experiments and going to extreme
environments on earth to to address this
question
what's fascinating to me is that there
are two really
well
thought out fleshed out scenarios
for how life might have started on earth
and they're completely mutually
exclusive
so on the one hand
you have uh some people who are saying
that life started on the surface so like
four billion years ago there may have
just been a few volcanic islands popping
up through
above the ocean surface and you might
have little ponds there and in those
ponds as they as they
filled up with water and dried out you
would have a series of chemical
reactions that might have actually
produced rna and then might have been
able to encapsulate the rna into
protocells
so
there you got some people who say that's
where life started you have other people
who say nope life started at the bottom
of the ocean um at these uh vents
in the in the sea floor where you have
these magnificent sort of mineral towers
that form as as hot mineral-laced water
shoots up from the earth's interior and
as that water and those chemicals get
pushed through
the these chimneys
all sorts of interesting chemistry
happens and then you could actually
start to
it could start to build up on itself and
you start to produce the molecules that
will eventually become our genes you
start to produce membranes and might
eventually become our cell walls and so
on um
so you know they might both be right
maybe one of them is right for earth and
one of them is right for a moon in orbit
around saturn um it's hard it's hard to
say
um but you know along the way you know
the these uh
lines of research they lead to amazing
discoveries um very practical ones uh in
some cases so for example
right now in the pandemic a really
important way that scientists
figure out
uh you know whether you know sarge kov2
is infecting someone or what kind of
sarge kov2 what variant it is they use a
special kind of dna sequencing called
nanopore
sequencing um it's a pretty new uh
technology it's like the sequencer is
like is smaller than your iphone you
plug it into your computer
um that was actually developed by people
who were trying to understand the origin
of life because uh the the fundamental
way that it works is that dna gets run
through a little pore
and
that was something that people were
thinking about when they were thinking
well okay when you have these protocells
they're gonna need to get stuff in and
out
we have very elaborate channels and and
various portals in our cells but well
how would this all begin um it couldn't
be a perfectly sealed bubble stuff is
going to get in and out and someone was
like well maybe they just have a simple
pore
maybe you could get a genetic molecule
in and out and then he says someone
named david diemer
university of california at santa cruz
he said
wait a minute like if i'm pulling dna in
and out through a pore it's going to
generate an electric uh current a tiny
tiny current
and we might be able to measure that
um and 30 years later that's how we are
one of the tools we're using in the
pandemic that's sick what about viruses
then are viruses alive
again it really depends on who you ask
i mean i one morning um i had a
virologist email me and tell me of
course viruses are not alive and any
expert would tell you that and then that
afternoon another one said well of
course viruses are alive and any expert
will tell you that
um so you know as a science writer as a
sort of a chronicler of science it's
kind of a an awkward position to be in
because you know
people
ask me questions as if there's some sort
of you know clear-cut answers that i'm
i can refer to whose signs do you go
with yeah
well you know i mean
science is you know
debate
and conflict is at the heart of science
there's nothing wrong with with debates
you know just as long as that they're
you know meaningful ones and this is a
very meaningful one because
um it really forces us to think about
well what are viruses and themselves how
do they work and you know what do what
does it take for something to be alive
and and you know what do we even mean
when we're using these these terms the
thing about viruses is that
if you line them up next to a cell
they're very different they're not just
much smaller than a cell but you know a
cell is full
of atp like i mentioned our fuel
there's just constant metabolism going
on molecules are being built other ones
are being torn apart they're pulling in
things from their environment it's this
just this this uh you know buzzing hive
of activity
you look at a virus
um just
what scientists call a virion just a
little thing floating around on its own
it's just a little protein shell
with
some jeans inside
just wrapped up night nice and tight
that's it it's it's not doing anything
to keep itself going
what has to happen for a virus to
replicate
is that it has to fuse with a cell
and it goes in and now the cell
basically just starts treating the
viruses genes like its own genes
it starts to make those viral proteins
those viral proteins then take over the
cell and make the cell make
new viruses which then leave the cell to
go and affect other ones
so you know one of the architects of
that nasa working definition of life
was asked
well if life is this chemically
self-sustaining system capable of
darwinian evolution
um our virus is alive
and he said you know according this
definition no they don't make the cut
you know they don't they can't sustain
themselves
other people say well you can't
understand viruses without looking at
them as being part of life you know
viruses evolve i mean just look at the
variants that are making our lives
miserable you know the delta variant
didn't exist before october of last year
it evolved from earlier forms of the
virus
and
so and
it it follows all the same rules of
evolution that animals or plants do it's
it's a
classic
evolving thing
so um
so so p so people make a number of
arguments about um how viruses really
are alive based on a number of different
ways of looking at it um
and um
you know it it could be that there may
actually be viruses that really blur the
line and and
could
make this even more interesting because
there are certain viruses that
you know they have genes for things that
are not just for making new viruses you
know they have genes for building
proteins they have genes for
photosynthesis
and they just carry those genes along
and then once they get inside the cell
they basically like tell the cell like
okay
here's what you're going to be doing now
you know you're going to be
photosynthesizing in a different way
you're going to be capturing sunlight
and turning that into molecules that are
better for making viruses than for
making more cells so let's get to work
um
and you know it's so there are ways in
which you know viruses themselves may
make this question even harder to answer
i had a geneticist on a while ago
talking about how we could engineer life
to reach other space systems
and he was saying that one of the things
dr david sinclair's talking about some
of this stuff in his longevity research
lab in harvard where you have particular
types of viruses that are turned on and
turned off
with antibiotics or with uh particular
types of bacteria i think and then
you could have he had created this idea
of a human who had
photosynthetic skin and you'd need i
think he worked out in order to survive
you'd need about two
tennis
courts
worth of skin
just laid out
um but he kind of imagined these green
humans that wouldn't need food you
wouldn't need to carry all the food with
you because you can just have you your
tennis court of wings stuck out to the
sides and then you can just get all of
your sunlight and you could exist like
that so yeah it's um
it's funny how all of this stuff comes
together so if
it seems like there's quite a bit of
chaos trying to work out what's going on
here did you arrive or discover a better
definition of life
i
i think the most radical uh proposal um
that i came across was
uh from a philosopher named carol
cleland at the university of colorado
who said don't try to define life
definitions are pointless you're wasting
your time
and you know this really like bothers a
a lot of scientists because they think
that um that definitions are just part
of what they do
um but in fact um you know
if you're not careful you can get into
sort of language traps
so for example um
you think about
water you know think about an alchemist
trying to define water for you in 1500
and alchemists did and they would and
what they would do is they would like
list off some characteristics that had
like well water something that's
transparent something that's wet
something that dissolves certain things
like that's my definition of water
but
then there were certain things that
looked a lot like water but were
dissolving other things i could dissolve
certain kinds of metal so were they
water well they would actually say like
oh we're going to call this royal water
and then you'd have a problem when it
got cold
and this liquid water froze and became
something called ice is ice water well
strictly speaking by the division no
um and so you know even leonardo da
vinci writes in his journal about how
frustrating it is that water just seems
to be whatever you want it to be it's
just maddening
so the definitions did not help in
understanding
what what was necessary was a few more
centuries of research and the invention
of chemistry as a science
the way to talk about
water is to talk about it in terms of
with with in a theory
a theory of atoms and elements of
molecules you know and then you can talk
about
molecules of two hydrogen atoms and one
oxygen atom and now you're really having
a meaningful understanding of it so
so what carol cleveland argues is that
what we really need is a theory of life
which we do not have yet there are
people working on it but until we have
that
if we just try if we waste time coming
up with
hundreds more definitions of life and
yelling at each other about it that's
time we could have spent moving towards
a real theory of life
yeah it's interesting
thinking about that i think i think it
was you that said it's like trying to
describe red
or effort
it's always described in terms of
analogies and then we have this sort of
imperfect language so you just end up
playing lexical brazilian jiu jitsu in
an effort to try and work out the
closest approximation of the thing that
you mean and then as soon as you make an
analogy the analogy is always slightly
imperfect because by definition it isn't
the thing you're talking about it's a
thing like the thing that you're talking
about
and um
yeah i'm glad i'm glad i don't work in
the theory of life business
frankly
well it's it's it's not for the faint of
heart that's for sure and you know in in
the book i actually write about you know
some figures in history who
who really tried to go out there to
life's edge the title of the book and
you know that edge where
you're trying to figure out what divides
life from non-life
and they've
they've flamed out they've made terrible
mistakes and they've they've gone down
you know
gone down into obscurity for
for
coming up with crazy ideas that really
just
we're completely off base um you know we
we
we
we tend to think of science as just
nothing but a sort of a series of
triumphs and a
linear progression from
one deep insight to the next and you
know that's not how science works
science is is full of branches in
different directions many of which just
lead to complete failure who is one of
those failures
well i talk in the beginning of the book
about a physicist named john butler
burke who um he was
at cambridge and he was working at this
lab where in the
early 1900s where you know the electron
had just been discovered you know
quantum physics was was being uh
uncovered for the first time in places
like this lab
um
radioactivity was was another thing that
was fascinating people there because it
could tell you about how atoms worked in
this very strange way
and people were fascinated by the
element radium for example and they they
would you know there would be dance
performances where the dancers were
dressed in radium
clothing that glowed in the dark
um and so in this context burke uh
thought well maybe
you know radioactivity is is at the at
the maybe that's what life's about you
know maybe radioactivity is the
organizing principle behind life
and so he ran an experiment where he
took some sterilized beef broth and he
dropped some radium into it and then let
it stay there overnight and then he
went into the lab the next day
and he saw that a layer had formed on
top of the broth and so he scooped some
of that out put it in her
slide looked at it under a microscope
and he convinced himself that he was
seeing um
microbes um teeny tiny structures that
grew and became more complex over time
that seemed to divide
and these were much smaller than
microbes and
but they seemed to be alive to him or at
least to be right on the border and so
he named them radiobs after
radioactivity
published a paper about them wrote a
book about them was just the the talk of
the town i mean people were saying that
burke was important as darwin
and this glory lasted for maybe a year
until some other scientists re-ran the
experiments and showed that it was all
um a fluke from bad chemistry you know
if you use distilled water this just
didn't happen
and that was it and he for the rest of
his life uh
insisted that um
that he uh
uh had been right and that radios really
were there at the at the at that life's
edge
um and uh you know nobody knows who
burke is now um
you know in a way he was a real pioneer
you know he actually used the term
artificial life for the first time for
what he had done
you know trying to make life in a lab he
was trying to do it um but uh but we
don't remember him because he was
playing this very very dangerous game
dangerous status job being a scientist
life's edge the search for what it means
to be alive will be linked in the show
notes below if people want to keep up to
date with what you do where should they
go
uh my website is carlsimmer.com and i'm
carl zimmer on twitter i love it thanks
carl what's happening people thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that episode then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you